voilà friot tout cela que tu y es a pris
tout cela pour l'afrique
ça promet
[Musique]
dans le cadre de mes missions
j'interviens dans des ateliers
parentalité dans toutes les maternelles
de mon secteur sur des thèmes comme le
sommeil le biberon le cododo et les
écrans parce qu'on s'aperçoit que c'est
vraiment un domaine de santé publique
depuis environ 4 5 ans donc on fait ces
ateliers avec les maîtresses les
directrices pour donner des petites
astuces aux parents pour pallier à ces
temps d'écran
serge tisseron pédopsychiatre a dit pas
d'écran avant trois ans les enfants de
cet âge là ils ont besoin de manipuler
avec leurs petits doigts pour pouvoir
les muscles et tout simplement avec des
jeux comme comme celui ci par exemple
trouver les bonnes couleurs en mémoire
faire des puzzles d'encastrement des
caps la de la pâte à modeler des jeux de
transvasement à la plage
la poupée les enfants d'écoles
maternelles de deux ans et demi trois
ans et demi ont souvent des troubles du
langage et troubles de la concentration
et l'histoire du soir est très
importante pour ces enfants là pour
favoriser le langage pour donner du
vocabulaire aux enfants en fait on
s'aperçoit en petite section que
beaucoup d'enfants quand ils ont un
livre dans les mains il
ils font comme sur un gsm ils font
passer les images sauf que sur le livre
ça ne marche pas donc on ainsi vraiment
les parents à inscrire leurs enfants en
médiathèque pour pouvoir déchiffrer en
grande section et faire l'acquisition de
la lecture au cp tour et petit ours brun
tour c'est le grand tour et petite
housse et le petit rang tour se sont
peut-être tout seul sans moi se
disputent ensuite serge tisseron dit pas
de jeux vidéo avant 6 ans il ya beaucoup
d'enfants maternelle grande section par
exemple qui jouent avec leur dada ou les
cousins les tontons l'est pas par c'est
souvent les garçons
c'est des jeux de guerre et après ils
refont pareil dans la cour de récréation
faut savoir qu'un enfant ne connaît pas
la différence entre le virtuel et le
réel la reine jusqu'à l'âge de 6 ans
donc s'il fait un jeu vidéo où il fait
la bagarre avec quelqu'un qui tue
quelqu'un pour lui c'est la vérité
[Musique]
ensuite une d'ipad internet seul avant
neuf ans internet c'est super dangereux
pour les tout petits
il y à des images de violence des images
de pornographie et s'est pas du tout
adapté aux enfants de cet âge là dans
mes ateliers parentalité souvent les
mamans elles ont un enfant en maternelle
un enfant primaire et un enfant au
collège et elle nous relate que ben oui
moi à la maison j'ai des soucis avec mon
ado qui est tout le temps sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui s'endort très
tard et à l'école qui en échec que
scolaire donc on reparle énormément du
sommeil et des quatre temps sans écran
[Musique]
le premier temps c'est pas d'écran avant
d'aller à l'école pas d'écran le mat
faut savoir qu'un enfant de deux ans et
demi trois ans et demi a une capacité de
concentration de 5 10 minutes donc déjà
qu'ils regardent les écrans le matin son
taux de concentration baisse le deuxième
c'est pas d'écran pendant le repas ça
c'est très dur parce qu'en fait les
parents regardent les actualités ya
l'adolescent qui avec son gsm
le primaire qui avec la tablette donc
les temps de repasser compliqué pour
beaucoup de familles
je les incite énormément à partager un
quart d'heure vingt minutes le soir en
famille pour pouvoir dialoguer le plus
possible qu'est ce que tu as fait
aujourd'hui à l'école qu'est ce que tu
as mangé à la cantine pour pouvoir
ouvrir le langage ouvrir la parole et
discuter le plus possible en famille
le troisième temps pas d'écran le soir
avant de dormir les écrans le soir ça
fasse et pas du tout l'endormissement et
on préconise un petit livre le quatrième
temps c'est pas d'écran dans la chambre
s'ils ont un écran dans la chambre les
regarde jusqu'à pas d'heure et ils sont
très fatigués enfants de 1 à 5 ans doit
dormir entre 10 et 14 heures par nuit
s'il n'a pas ce quota là il va être
fatigué héritable capricieux donne moi
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on s'aperçoit depuis depuis
quelques années qu'on oriente énormément
vers les ophtalmologues
tout simplement parce que
les enfants regardent de plus en plus
les écrans de près que ça soit au niveau
du gsm ou de la tablette ou de la télé
et au niveau des orthophonistes
il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui vont déjà
chez l'orthophoniste avant d'entrer à
l'école parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
langage du tout ils ne font pas de
phrase